uh we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 let's go to our next caller from
the 5 7 1 area code caller what's your
name where are you calling from and
what's on your mind today
hello David my name is Grover I call
before this has two things to say don't
donate one dollar to your show because I
really enjoy your videos and you are the
future of course in opinion independent
media thank you
and the other thing that I have is um
the other thing that I have a question
is what it is harder your thumb sorry
for asking this energy a Jewish
Argentinean guy about why do people kid
you because I don't know like honestly I
am not sure what like believe it or not
I don't know why like I'm I'm I'm a kid
but I don't know why let's go ahead a
little I don't know either you know you
know Grover I don't this has been one of
the main questions in my life why do so
many people hate Jews and Jews have been
a scapegoat for thousands and thousands
of years and you know sometimes we have
to just accept that we may never fully
know the answer and we can still try to
root out anti-semitism even even if we
never really understand why so many
people hate Jews emotions can be a very
irrational thing yes certainly that is
true when it comes to hate yes but
thanks Grover for the $1 contribution as
Grover clearly knows about we're in the
middle of a YouTube advertiser boycott
which has put the show in crisis we're
trying to recoup that money through a
patreon pledge page at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show
Grover always great to hear from you
thanks for calling in saying thank you
all right very good Grover Grover is a
good guy I like where that does it for
calls we will take a break and be back
after this we've got audience questions
to answer and then the bonus show it's
all happening I'm glad you're with us
today